Okay, so how you doing
I'm doing great, you know just um
Um... um
Just doing what needs to be done and
What does that mean?
I'm sorry, Dad, um
Why don't we just have lunch and talk. We can do that, right?
Please
You think that you have this under control.
I understand why I do things. It doesn't make me any different
You're just embarrassed because I was like, you know, I was like this amazing thing like your special creation or something
and you don't like who I am now.
Yeah, who are you Nick?
This is me Dad here this is who I am.
This is not you. This is not you Nick.
What are you doing? Huh? You always got to be controlling everything all the time
Let me, let me book you a room
No Dad.
At a hotel for a couple of nights.
I didn't want it to go like this
My son has gone missing Nicholas Sheff. S-H-E-F-F.
There's no one by that name sir.
There are moments
That I look at him
This kid that I raised
Who I thought I knew inside and out and I wonder who he is.
I thought we were close
I thought we were closer than most fathers and sons. Why?
I felt better than ever had so I just kept doing it
This isn't us. This is not who we are
My son is out there somewhere and I don't know what he's doing.
I don't know how to help him.
You can't.
I don't feel like I have a disease. This isn't like cancer. This is my choice. I've put myself here.
I failed.
I can't do it alone.
I need to find a way to fill this black hole in me.
I still have a family. I want them to be proud of me.
What you have you're gonna find it again, you're gonna get it back.
Do you know how much I love you?
I love you more than everything.
Everything?
Everything.